let's talk about volunteer work and how
sharing some of your time can make the
ultimate heroic difference in some cases
let us introduce you to sally reynolds
this month's hospice hero
as a hospice volunteer i find that i
need
a little bit of solace from
the activity of being a volunteer and i
seek mine
at the library and it gives me comfort
it gives me peace
and it also gives me by reading gives me
that insight
into human traits different human traits
as a southwest medical hospice volunteer
again
there are many life lessons to learn and
i have augmented that um
i have a natural feeling i believe for
being a hospice volunteer
it started early on i don't have as far
as
life lessons go i don't have a fear of
death i don't have a fear
of the transition i prefer to honor the
person who is inflicted as
the whole person not the stigma of the
medical condition and it comes naturally
for me
and i think it all started through
reading and that is why
i choose to come here because when you
read you develop friends you develop
empathy and compassion
through the characters and it allows you
through
my long life to take that skill
and apply it elsewhere i would encourage
i would fully encourage anyone to become
a hospice hero with southwest medical i
you know it's it's being human it's it's
a skill that we all have
it's a feeling we all have and sometimes
i think maybe just a little bit of fear
or trepidation
keeps people apart but when you get
beyond that and get with the patient
and you're in their home or you're at a
medical facility
you're one on one with them and they
have a life story to share with you
as well as your life story with them and
it's
the exchange is profound my overall
feelings for hospice and the benefit
comes from my experience with two dear
friends who have passed
and knowing that just sharing the joy of
everyday life
sharing what time they have left they
still have priorities to set
be it through their children in fact my
two friends
in hawaii who have passed at a very
young age
her son one son just got married and he
brought me back there as auntie or
second mom
and the other girlfriend who passed her
daughter is now in law school
and she came here two weeks ago and i
got to hug her
and you feel that you feel that you were
part of that life
and it goes on their life goes on
congratulations and thank you so much
sally for more information on southwest
medical hospice or to become a volunteer
yourself
call 702-671-1111 or visit the website
on your screen
remember there are virtual and in-person
opportunities as a hospice volunteer
las vegas now